okay do you want to hear about a
religious scam that a pastor and his
wife did or do you want to hear about a
psychic dream mark Ruffo had 20 years
ago uh religious scam a pastor and his
wife are accused of defrauding their
followers for over $1.3 million I'm
using that money to renovate their
house the dumbest [__] like at least buy
a house in a different city than the
congregation lives you dumb [__] like I
just just go get a different house where
is that I'm going I'm going to look for
I'm going to find I'm going to find it
again right now yo you dummy MC derson
everybody knows man how much a passer
makes you can't be putting 1.3 into your
house you dumb [__] go buy a house in
like a different state you know yep so
uh it's in
Denver um wow and expensive in Denver
yeah and he's and this is how it's he
shared a message for his congregation so
his followers and all that he said after
months of prayers and cues from God he
was going to start selling
cryptocurrency he announced in a Youtube
video um signature in silver Banks had
collapsed weeks earlier signaling that
they needed to look for more ways to
find money he said with Divine wisdom he
was quote setting the rails for God's
wealth transfer end quote I don't even
know what that means I don't even know
either I love the fact that they put a
quote out where I understand all the
words but I don't understand what the
sentence means together dude and there
was there was I was reading it there was
a couple other quotes and one of the
quotes from him said God told me to do
this and then at the end of it it said
God told me wrong and I was like what
first is he blaming God for telling him
the wrong thing who is this oh I was
just going to make a joke I can't make
that joke wait a second this dude threw
God under the bus straight under the bus
he was like [__] God told me to steal
but didn't he say that
Thou shalt not steal I was going to say
isn't it one of the basis of your
religion is to not steal like don't
doesn't he literally as a pastor
preached that every Sunday like I I I
don't even get it I don't even
understand it it doesn't even make me
sense he was like yo my God made me do
it God did like [__] he's like DJ
khed over here like what the [__] whoa
how if you are in his
congregation I'm showing up to that
house and breaking that kitchen you are
I'm showing up to the house and
destroying everything that was my money
that went into your wall great I'm
taking that piece of that wall this dude
is like dude I wouldn't have done that
but God told God was like Hey steal
their money why do they need it and not
only steal their money but don't give it
to the poor you know what you need
another wing on your house dude he said
after dude I hope he put a hot tub in I
[__] hope he put a hot tub in bro so
in a video last week he addressed the
accusations and acknowledged that people
had bought his cryptocurrency and are
stuck and unable to sell he said we
launched an exchange um The Exchange
technology failed things went downhill
and from right now we're just waiting on
some help from the Lord wait a second so
he sold crypto to his congregation
correct so he didn't even sell anything
that they can have
tangent he was like Hey currenc I have
this fairy
dust I and by the way his congregation's
got some money
huh whoa I'm Denver apparently dud tast
bad here's the quote either quote either
I misheard God or God is still not done
with this project and he is going to do
a new thing end quote what we're praying
for and what we're believing for still
is that God is going to perform a
miracle God is going to work a miracle
in the financial sector and that
everyone who invest is going to be able
to receive money back end quote last
sentence of the article a court hearing
is scheduled for Monday and that was two
days ago Dude did he say I misheard God
what was that oh you didn't say steal
their money
oh yo I thought he said hey sorry
everybody I was just listening to God he
said I thought he said steal your money
he didn't say steal your money he said
whatever rhymes with steal deal your
money that is I Mish her god dude that's
is that not a t-shirt somewhere it's a
hilarious book name cuz you know some
people are like are you there God and
he's like I Mard you God what' you say
again oh my bad like oh yo a title of a
book would be I misheard you God what'
you say again be [__] ridiculous if
you
just I can't make religious jokes on
here that I want to make I don't want to
offend anybody is it it it doesn't sound
like a religious book though I heard
you like if he if he wrote that yeah and
said I misheard you God like what' you
say again I misheard God is like the C
I've never heard anyone Dodge
accountability like that is yeah just I
just I just misheard God I I I think the
shower was running too hard and I I at
one point in time I was I was just take
getting the soap out of my ear and I
thought he said steal their money but I
just and I was like are you sure Lord
and he said it again I just I guess I
misheard him that by the way if
you if he said that and you believe him
you believe in the wrong God you deserve
to lose all your money if you believe
that this dude just misheard God and
you're like no he's a good dude he just
uh he misheard god um delusional oh
delusional delusional it's pretty crazy
to have the balls to say I misheard God
and also it's it's crazy to me to think
he has that crazy crazy of a
congregation and a following that him
and this company made over a million
dollars in in sales and that
cryptocurrency is [__]
insane what do you think we should start
selling apparently cryptocurrency to
people who believe in God key is to sell
something God God coin god coin
dude is genius Godin God coin with the
smaller coin of Jesus coin no no just
God coin god coincoin god coin is a
great name for a
crypto
oh oh and just a picture of God on there
just we could call the stock the Holy
Spirit what's the stock like the
cryptocurrency like you know obviously
if you have a cryptocurrency like you
have a stock in that crypto and we'll
just name it the whole like the the
abbreviation will be h l y s sprt
dude this is not a terrible idea
apparently based on how that guy did it
I could make a lot of money I mean the
here's what I think the key to re this
is what he really tapped into the key to
scamming people and getting their money
is having them buy something that you is
there's no physical it's not a physical
form it's simply yo dude it it's why I
never got into it because it's just and
I'm an old dude it's hard for me to wrap
my brain around giving money money to
something I can't put in my hand yeah
Now Stocks I understand stocks and bonds
and all that stuff but I could go get
physical copies I guess if I wanted to
do you know what I mean yeah yeah
absolutely so like it's just weird it's
always been I know it's old and I'm old
and bl blah blah but like I just this
why I never got into it because I'm like
wait you can make this money on your
computer yeah I can also buy it but I
can never have anything and I can't
really spend it like I can't go to the
ATM and get money well I mean I mean
again if you buy here's the thing though
like so what the cryptocurrency is is
like if like Bitcoin for example right
yeah if you buy a Bitcoin that Bitcoin
is worth whatever the stock is worth no
I got it so like that's so you can
essentially change that into money you
would just have to withdraw a said
Bitcoin you just have to take the money
out like it's but I can't I can't I
can't go to the ATM machine there are
Bitcoin machines actually that you can
withdraw are there yeah are you sure
legitimately I'm not
kidding I might change my mind on this
stuff your voice is there a Mario
Brother's Bitcoin no what would you name
it oh I got a joke for you what's what's
Mario's favorite type of
pants denim denim denim yeah it's the
same thing but you ruined it by just
saying d d well I figured well since I
said it and then you said I get a good
joke I figured that might be the answer
to it you didn't even want to try and
like come up with it answer though you
just said the same thing yeah probably
not well done